what did you think about the jake paul
versus tyron woodley fight
uh well i thought i mean i was in bias i
thought tyron won
um i had five rounds of three
and again this maybe this is my bias in
the way i was seeing it i thought he was
more effective with the striking and he
was more aggressive now jake had more
volume
um but that was the only like thing i
would give him and i guess a lot of
people just didn't see it that way they
thought he landed more significant
punches i just didn't think anyone
really did any damage
it was a split decision split decision
yeah
were you surprised
um
well there's the thing so the thing i
said when i went in to fight him i said
we don't really maybe he's good maybe
he's not we have no we really have no
idea to this point you know
and so
i knew tyrone was a lot better boxing
than i was and so i thought okay
tyron's i think it's a good likelihood
that tyron beats him up
um but there's the chance that jake's
kind of good at this and i think that's
kind of what played out is
he's kind of good at it even if you saw
the way i saw it he still was impressive
in his showing and he's obviously put a
lot of time into it so he's
he's not bad we'll say that much you
know but isn't it surprising to you that
like uh elite level
athlete
combat athlete
lost to somebody who just takes it
really seriously but is nevertheless not
elite level
um hmm but i think boxing's a really
specific rule set uh so we'll speak
about tyranny not myself tyra had good
striking but obviously it was his first
boxing match ever um and within mixed
martial arts you have the
the fear of the takedown and the fear of
the kick and fear of other things to go
along with the punching and so if you
look at tyron throughout his mma crew a
lot of times what set up his punches
were like level change fakes at a
takedown they dropped boom and then
something comes over the top right so
there's many more elements to worry
about mixed martial arts whereas boxing
there's only one it was his first fight
yes i thought everyone was gonna win i
thought this was gonna happen but like i
said i mean it's pretty evident that
jigs
he's not bad at boxing he's pretty solid
you know he gets in there and works hard
at it i guess
out of 10 times how many times do you
think jake wins i guess turn he gets
tyrone
they fight again and again and again
like iterative yeah so i mean i i part
of the thing is
okay so jake's corner said you need a
knockout going into the eighth round
right so i think they thought
maybe they're trying to motivate him but
i i don't see it that way because if
they were actually thought that he was
winning why would they encourage him to
take a dumb risk when tyron has cleared
his knockout power right it's a really
stupid coaching philosophy if that's
what you're thinking so you obviously
are thinking hey this is actually in the
balance it's competitive
um and i feel like tyron thought maybe
he was winning and didn't have the
urgency necessary and so i think he
there's a chance he turns it up a lot
hmm
man i would want to watch him again
before i i so yeah i have this problem
with my personality here's my
personality lex um i have an issue with
not being able to give really exact
answers so i hate giving you an answer
that like
i don't feel like is 100 calculated yeah
so um i would like to see them go once
more because i would like to see hey can
tire if because if tyron can turn the
pace and nj can't handle it then i think
it's an eight one or nine two right
um if it goes the exact same way and
maybe tyrone was a close split decision
i'm saying oh it's probably close every
single time we're probably gonna get a
five to five type of thing you know so
it's like
i feel like out of one match it's not
totally indicative of what the future is
gonna look like i feel like tara would
get a knockout and then you would still
be in the same place
like not knowing
not knowing what to predict
you